Speaker 1: So in the middle of the entire
California gubernatorial recall, which we
covered yesterday and already earlier today
on the show, an insane bombshell story dropped
on the basis of a forthcoming book from journalist
Bob Woodward and Robert Costa, where there
are a number of disturbing and dystopian claims
and stories that are made and told.
And we have to start with what may be the
craziest one, which is that General Mark Milley
was so afraid that in the aftermath of losing
to Joe Biden, Donald Trump would launch nuclear
weapons that Meely had to assure China Trump's
not completely out of control and merely even
having an emergency meeting with other top
military brass to try to figure out a way
of if Trump tried to do this, can we actually
stop him from doing it?
And we'll talk about whether this would even
really be possible.
OK, so let's start with the CNN article reporting
on the contents of the book.
Listen to this.
Two days after the January six attack on the
capital, Trump's top military adviser, Joint
Chiefs Chairman General Mark Milley, single
handedly took secret action to limit Trump
from potentially ordering a dangerous military
strike or launching nukes, according to Paral,
a new book by legendary journalist Bob Woodward
and veteran Washington Post reporter Robert
Costa Woodward.
And cost a right that merely deeply shaken
by the assault of January six, was certain
that Trump had gone into a serious mental
decline in the aftermath of the election,
with Trump now all but manic screaming at
officials and constructing his own alternate
reality about endless election conspiracies.
If five percent of this is accurate, Trump
was completely losing his mind behind the
scenes exactly as we believed he was doing,
merely worried that Trump could go rogue,
the authors write.
You never know what a president's trigger
point is, merely told a serious, serious senior
staff.
In response, Milley took an extraordinary
action and called a secret meeting in his
Pentagon office on January eight to review
the process for military action, including
launching nuclear weapons.
Speaking to senior military officials in charge
of the National Military Command Center, the
Pentagon's war room merely instructed them
not to take orders from anyone unless he was
involved.
Now, is this even.
Does this break chain of command?
We're going to talk about that in a second.
No matter what you were told, you do the procedure,
you do the process, and I'm part of the procedure,
Milley told the officers, according to the
book.
He then went around the room, looked each
officer in the eye and asked them to verbally
confirm.
They understood.
Got it?
Milley asked, according to the book.
Yes, sir.
M.E. considered it an oath, the authors write.
Peril is based on more than 200 interviews
with firsthand participants and witnesses
and paints a chilling picture of Trump's final
days in office.
The book, Woodward's Third on the Trump Presidency,
recounts behind the scenes moments of Trump's
unhinged and explosive actions, yelling at
senior advisers and aides as he desperately
sought to cling to power.
It includes reporting of the events leading
up to the January six riot.
Trump's reaction and newly revealed details
about Trump's January five Oval Office showdown
with Mike Pence, Woodward and cost to obtain
documents, calendars, diaries, emails, meeting
notes, transcripts and other records.
One other part of this, and then we'll get
into some some discussion.
Milli's fear was based on his own observations
of Trump's erratic behavior.
His concern was magnified by the events of
January six and the extraordinary risk the
situation posed to U.S. national security
merely had already had two back channel phone
calls with China's top general, who was on
high alert over the chaos in the US.
The then Meely received a blunt phone call
from Nancy Pelosi.
Woodward and Costa obtained a transcript of
the call during which he tried to reassure
Pelosi the nukes were safe.
Pelosi pushed, pushed back.
What I'm saying to you is that if they couldn't
even stop him from an assault on the capital,
who even knows what else he may do?
And is there anybody in charge at the White
House who was doing anything but kissing his
fat?
But over all of this, Pelosi continued, you
know, he's crazy.
He's been crazy for a long time, according
to Woodward, and constantly responded, Madam
Speaker, I agree with you on everything.
And then what maybe is the key revelation
here is merely becoming so afraid of Trump's
actions hardly ended up back channeling with
Chinese officials and saying it's going to
be OK, we've got this under control.
So we are quite literally talking here about
a president going nuclear, an actual lunatic
as president.
And it's the same people who thought that
this Trump was the guy that it made sense
to make a president who now don't want the
vaccine.
So think about that for a second.
Now, there's a real question here.
And a bunch of people emailed me about the
saying is merely, in a sense, overstepping
authority here.
Later, we're going to get to clips of Trump
calling what Millie did, treason.
I think that that's outrageous.
But did Millie overstep authority here?
I think the most sort of balanced and sober
reaction to this is that ultimately Millie
would not have authority over Trump when it
comes to nukes and preventing him from launching
them.
At the end of the day, whatever system Millie
puts in place as a chairman of the Joint Chiefs,
Trump could fire Millie and then replace him
with someone who ultimately will allow Trump
to launch nukes.
Now, what I think Millie was trying to do
here is given the limited amount of time that
Trump would have to do this.
Remember, the riots were on January 6th.
Milli's meeting was on January 8th. Trump
was leaving office on January 20th or 21st.
I don't remember Inauguration Day at this
point.
So you're talking about under two weeks?
My belief is Millie knows that ultimately
Trump can fire him and put some yes person
in who will let Trump launch nukes.
Ultimately, Trump can get his launch order
through, but merely knowing Trump probably
realizes Trump has this sort of limited attention
span.
And eventually, if it's too difficult to get
it done, Trump will look the other way or
his attention will go to some other shiny
object.
So obviously, at the end of the day, it comes
down to, you know, the nuclear silo officers
to actually launch missiles.
It is ultimately at the discretion of the
president.
But my understanding is Milli's idea here
was let's just make it difficult enough so
that Trump would have to fire me and maybe
other people in order to get this done and
maybe that prevents it from happening.
The real story here is the mere fact that
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs was so afraid
this would happen is an incredible historic
story that goes to the unhinged and erratic
nature of Donald Trump.
A little bit later on in the show, we're going
to get to some of the reaction from Trump
to the story coming out.